it was clear from the moment he touched
down for a new life across the pond
that there'd be no escape from the
cameras for prince harry and his family
good job hey look a duck
it's keeping their young son out of view
of one of the most
voracious paparazzi packs in the world
though that's prompted the couple into
yet another
legal confrontation this lawsuit filed
in los angeles
accuses unidentified photographers of
invading the family's privacy
alleging they've cut holes in fences and
even flown
low over their beverly hills home
hawking the photos to the highest bidder
in a statement the couple's lawyer said
every individual and family member in
california
is guaranteed by law the right to
privacy in their home
no drones helicopters or telephoto
lenses
can take away that right the duke and
duchess of sussex are filing this
lawsuit
to protect their son's right to privacy
in their home without intrusion by
photographers
and to uncover and stop those who seek
to profit
from these illegal actions the couple
say they accept there is legitimate
media interest in them but what's
happened in california has in their
words
crossed a red line it's clearly a
warning shot to anybody who
may want to publish these photos it's a
reminder they will take action
and they are able now to
either use subpoena powers to get
information about anybody
who is doing this activity so they can
go after people
it's not like we're short of photos but
yeah i mean at the end of the day
um there's still a huge amount of
interest in them but they
have certain rights and in california
you just can't photograph
people in their homes and that's where
they're bunkered down right now so
i guess with a pandemic people aren't
out and about and you're unlikely to
catch them in the same way as if there
wasn't one
it was incidents like this miley cyrus
posting a video of a drone
over her home that saw california
tighten laws on the paparazzi
but the clamor for celebrity photos has
only increased
what the sussexes say represents
intimidation
harassment and an added security threat
they've shown their willingness to go to
court
to fight for their privacy so far it's
done nothing
to make the attention go away greg milam
sky news los angeles